Hey Youtubers, what's up? Thank you everyone
that submitted questions for this week's
Marvel Q&A, lot's of Marvel stuff
going on right now.
This is mostly gonna focus on the
Avengers trailer. There were a few really
common questions that everyone had so I'm gonna start with those.
Big stuff first. There were two women in
the trailer that everyone was wondering about.
As for the first one here, the best
theory I've seen is that she's part
of Black Panther's honor guard and she's gonna
be part of a potential Wakanda plot.
In the comics Black Panther has a special
group of female warriors
that serve as, like, badass bodyguards. Marvel's
trying to get people used to the concept of
Black Panther before he shows up in a
movie. There are rumors that we'll
actually see Wakanda in the film
and we have Ulysses Klaw, Andy Serkis,
right here. So all things pointing to her being
a Black Panther related character.
In the vast vast realm of speculation
she could also be Black Panther's sister.
I think this is much less likely, like there's
a very slim chance.
Her name is Shuri and in the comics she takes the
mantle Black Panther
whenever he goes into a coma. At some
point really soon I'll do a dedicated
Black Panther video just for that
character because he's really interesting.
I just, I haven't spent a lot of time talking
about him yet. The really cool thing
about Black Panther stories is they
invoke a lot a mystical elements
which might lead to a Doctor Strange
point of cross over, not that I'm expecting
him to be in the Black Panther film.
Until we get confirmation, let's just say
she's a character tied to the Black Panther mythos.
Next mystery person in the trailer: this
woman doing something behind Thor
looking like she's
weaving a spell while he's getting the crap
shocked out of him. It looks like they're in the
middle of a fight
and she's weaving some sort of magic.
There's a lot of speculation she could
be Enchantress
or even Hela. For those that haven't read
the comics, Enchantress is the
older sister of Lorelei, this woman
from Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. Season 1,
she was actually really cool on that show.
Hela is the child of pre-Ragnarok Loki in the
comics.
After she comes of age, Odin gives her
dominion over Hel,
also known as Niffleheim, it's the Asgardian version of the afterlife.
I know it sounds like the Christian idea of
Hell, like as in Hell
and the Devil, but really the Asgardian
Hel isn't all bad and it does have a
physical location
on the World Tree like the Nine Realms,
it's just the lowest of the Nine Realms.
I'm not really sold on either one of
these theories completely yet.
It's possible that Thor could be imagining
what's going on there. There's this big
theory that Scarlet Witch
is going to give them all visions or
nightmares, however you want to look at it.
So parts of this movie could take place
inside the character's
heads. So in this scene here, for instance,
Thor could be witnessing his own
personal version of the afterlife. It
just feels like a very Joss Whedon thing to do,
deal with what's going on inside the
Avenger's heads.
Add to that that you have the Mind Gem
in Loki's staff here
which is responsible for Scarlet Witch
and Quicksilver's powers. So
if Scarlet Witch's powers are based on
the Mind Gem then she has some sort of
reality or mind altering powers. All
that's just speculation. I'm sure they're
gonna explain completely what her
powers are by the third act of the movie
but I think they're gonna be really
important to the plot and the creation
of the Vision
who largely remained absent from this
trailer which was kind of a bummer.
Just to go further into the Thor
afterlife stuff, so
Thor 3 is called Ragnarok and that's not
the Civil War clone
Ragnarok, this is like the Jack Kirby
idea of Ragnarok. He did a Ragnarok
storyline in the Thor comics.
It sounds like Thor 3 is going to deal with
the idea of the Asgardian afterlife,
you know, namely what happens to Asgardians after they die. Anthony Hopkins
even said that Odin died at the end of
Thor 2,
we just didn't see it happen. Ragnarok, in the mythological sense, is about the
cycle of death and rebirth.
So supposedly that's going to be going
on in the Marvel Universe in like a
cosmic way.
We really don't know how that's gonna play out so I don't want to speculate too much but if Thor is
gonna die at some point in one of these
movies
that he's going to have to visit the
afterlife so they'll have to introduce
that idea.
So it's possible that in Age of Ultron they
do that
in like a flash forward sequence where
he's imagining himself in the afterlife.
The only evidence to support any of that is
that Idris Elba
spoiled a post credits scene. I won't
mention what it is but I think most of
you know what I'm talking about.
It just involves two Asgardian
characters. Just in general think about
Marvel using the movie to tease
certain concepts like the afterlife,
magic, things that it's going to be
dealing with in a big way in future
films.
I feel like they do a really good job
of setting things up years in advance so
even if this character
isn't Hela or isn't Enchantress I
do think it's someone magic related
and I do think it's an Asgardian. So
now that we got through, like, the really big stuff
on to some more specific questions.
Glauber asks "Why are the Hulk's eyes red?
Is he being mind controlled by Scarlet
Witch?" I do think that that's a very real
possibility.
I mean if that's going to be going on
with the other characters, you know like
what did the Romanova girl show you,
then it's possible that she's the one
that makes the Hulk freak out. There's a
rumor that the Avengers have a
battle with Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
in the early parts of the film
before they obviously turn good and start
working with the Avengers.
Then you have this shot here of them on the
Quinjet looking like they just got there
asses handed to them. This could be after
Scarlet Witch messes with all their heads
and gives them crazy visions.
Next question, Laiquendi asks "Is Tony Stark
in the Hulkbuster because in the trailer you see
a shot with him in the armor
right after we saw the Hulkbuster." Yes,
that is him in the Hulkbuster. You
actually, there's a bigger shot, here, I'll just show it right here.
As you can see here, like, his Jarvis heads-up display is way wider.
I know it's a little confusing but he has
his normal armor on and then he jumps
into the Hulkbuster as if it's like a
shell. Next question.
"Why does Black Widow look like she's
about to receive surgery?"
So I think that's probably from a
flashback. You know, if the characters
are getting visions from Scarlet Witch
that she could be revisiting
when she got brainwashed and turned into an
assassin. There was a run in the comics
a little while ago that reimagined her
backstory.
She originally used to be a ballet
dancer and then was brainwashed and turned
into an assassin.
There was actually a script for that movie
that never got made so it could be them
incorporating some of those aspects.
Next question. KngdmHrts asks "What do
you think of the post that was put up by
the Latino review writer
where he talks about the spoilers for
Civil War, Thor 3,
Infinity War and Sony and Marvel in the
Spider-Man deal,
the MCU?" So whenever it comes to stuff
like that I'll always try to take it
with a grain of salt.
Most of it is just speculation on how
the Avengers
get blown apart. So the, like, the Avengers, the
roster will be different at the
end of Age of Ultron
so a lot of the speculation is what is going
to cause all these characters to go in
different directions.
Thor is going to be back in Asgard
during Thor 3, Captain America and
Iron Man are going to be at each others
throats in Civil War.
Both of those movies going to take place
right after Age of Ultron so
it just, it all depends on what happens
during Avengers 2.
The Spider-Man stuff is even further off
so it's more than likely
what's gonna happen with Spider-Man is
Sony will make another movie
but it'll end up being a co-production
with Marvel. So Marvel will have some authorship,
like they'll have some say in how the plot
goes and what the script is and who the
actors are.
I think in the next, like, four or five years Sony is
still going to retain
the lions share of Spider-Man profits regardless of who releases the film.
It just, it feels a lot more
plausible that Sony would make another film
and they'd get some help from Marvel
behind-the-scenes. And when I say help
I mean guidance. Super Six asks, so actually you had a really long question and a
lot a good stuff in it.
I'm actually gonna focus mostly on what
you said about Ultron creating the Vision.
So you suggested everyone creates the
thing that they fear. Ultron creates Vision.
What does that mean that he fears? So Ultron
I think ultimately fears humans thus he
creates
a near-perfect human which is what the
Vision is. There's really too many questions
about the specifics
of how that ends up happening because it
sounds like the Vision ends up getting
repurposed by Tony Stark
even if he starts out being created by
Ultron. It's just, the interesting idea is
that Ultron creates an Android that's too
perfect. So a lot of big stuff is going to be
happening in this movie. I know everyone's
wondering, you know,
"Are there too many characters, is there too
much stuff going on?" I'll say I trust Joss Whedon.
I think he was able to handle it all
although he looks like he doesn't wanna
make another Marvel film for a long long
time
even though he will probably still
retain a producer credit on future films.
I think the most interesting take away
is the way the film deals with the
concept of death.
There are a lot of rumors about a character
dying. There're certainly a lot of
candidates especially given
what's going on in Thor: Ragnarok or what's
probably going to be going on.
There will be a lot more footage they'll
release between now and the movie coming
out so there'll be a lot more for us to
talk about, hopefully some new scenes.
A lot of times the third and the fourth
trailer just end up being remixes of
previous trailers.
So hopefully they release new footage. I
wouldn't be too upset
if they didn't release footage of
the Vision just because I feel like that's
gonna be huge third act reveal.
Joss Whedon said they spent a ton of
time trying to get the color right just so
he didn't look too silly.
Moving along, congratulations to this
week's giveaway winners, Vlad Baird and
Sammy Lane,
you guys win Amazon gift cards, there's just, you
each win a $20 Amazon gift card. Just
message me on my channel for contact
details
so I can get your communication info. A lot of
you guys said you liked the idea of doing
comiXology gift certificate giveaways so
I'll try to find a way to do that with some of
my Marvel videos.
A lot of you have also asked about doing
another stream. I'll probably try and do another stream
next week sometime.
There's a lot of big stuff coming up. Arrow
and The Flash are premiering next week too
so I'm actually gonna be on a special
podcast, the CW Fancast is
gonna have me on.
It'll be Wednesday, I think, like right
before the episode
of Arrow airs. So if you wanna watch me talk
to some other people
about Arrow and the Flash that'll be
Wednesday at 4 p.m. Pacific time.
It should be a lot of fun, hopefully I
won't embarrass myself too much.
I tend to get a little over excited about
stuff.
Right now if you guys haven't seen it for like the
billionth time you can
click here to watch the Ultron trailer
again and you can click here to catch up on
Agent Carter from last night. Thank you so
much for watching. So everybody
high five, I'll see you tomorrow.